Hé mec pas de permis Emma jouera Sante
Mon Ami
parmi les guitares Monsieur Billy étrange
allez fils salut pixel d'accord
[Musique]
J'avais cinq ans et il en avait six nous montions sur des
chevaux faits de bâtons
il portait du noir et je portais du blanc il
gagnerait toujours le  combat bang bang il
m'a abattu bang bang j'ai touché le sol bang
bang ce son affreux bang bang
mon bébé
m'a abattu  nous avions l'
habitude de jouer bang bang je t'arrêtais
bang bang tu touchais le sol bang bang
ce son affreux bang bang j'avais l'habitude de
t'abattre  il est parti je ne sais pas pourquoi jusqu'à
ce jour parfois je pleure il n'a même pas
dit au revoir il n'a pas pris le temps de
mentir bang bang il m'a abattu bang bang
j'ai touché le sol bang bang cet horrible
fils bang bang
mon  bébé m'a abattu
[Musique]
mon bébé m'a arrêté